june's playstation plus may have leaked
xbox's games with gold has been
confirmed and more
according to a leak from deal labs june
2020's playstation plus free games
lineup will include god of war naruto
tabarito shinobi striker and nickelodeon
all-star brawl did i butcher that naruto
one probably the front sight has
correctly leaked ps plus free games for
the better part of a year so it's highly
likely that this will be the trio of
games featured next month ps plus
freebies always go live on the first
tuesday of each month so expect to see
these games up for grabs starting june
7th an official announcement from sony
should be coming tomorrow june 1st if
you own a playstation 5 with playstation
plus god of war might not be as exciting
since you already have access to it via
the ps plus collection but for those
still rocking the ps4 that haven't
played 2018's gow i can see this being a
really cool month the other two reported
offerings are brawlers so fighting game
fans will have their hands full in june
with two wildly different games shinobi
strikers features large-scale 4v4 fights
between naruto characters with different
ability sets meanwhile nickelodeon
all-star brawl is a smash bros-esque
brawler featuring an eclectic assortment
of cartoon characters from arguably the
best network for cartoons go ahead
cartoon network people yell at me in the
comments but maybe you only have an xbox
in your setup well don't worry microsoft
has unveiled the games with gold lineup
for june 2022. as usual xbox live gold
and gamepad's ultimate subscribers can
claim 4 free games next month even
colony is a city building game that asks
you to build a home for humans on an
alien planet and it's available to claim
all throughout june project highrise is
a 2d tower building game that solely
revolves around building and managing
skyscrapers you can claim it for free
from june 16th to july 15th super meat
boy is a challenging precision
platformer that will be free until june
15th meanwhile rascals is a zany action
platformer with cartoon visuals and more
than 60 side scrolling levels it will be
free in the second half of june in other
playstation and xbox news both logos are
listed under the summer game fest
partner lineup that was revealed today
other confirmed participants include 2k
games activision ea epic games sega and
square enix just to name a few another
confirmed studio is blueberry team and
their logo on the lineup has many fans
convinced that we'll see the rumored
silent hill remake at the game fest but
i'm not 100 convinced myself yet what
games are you hoping to see during
summer game fest not e3 season go wild
with your predictions in the comments
why and before we close out i just want
to remind all of you fellow trainers
that there will be a new pokemon scarlet
and violet trailer tomorrow at 6 am
pacific time 9 am eastern i am
incredibly excited for this one and i
don't know why okay sure i love pokemon
but lately the games haven't really been
doing anything for me and i'd much
rather spend my time playing the tcg
regardless it's always a fun time seeing
the weird reactions on social media to
new pokemon trailers so at least i have
that to look forward to can't wait to
talk about it all tomorrow i'll see you
then
you